mesdames et messieurs bonsoir à grand
événement mondial la ville d'al arish
chef-lieu du sinaï a été évacué
aujourd'hui par les troupes israéliennes
qui s'y trouvaient à quelques jours près
depuis 12 années le général commandant
en chef des forces israéliennes des
secteurs du secteur sud a remis
officiellement la ville au gouverneur
militaire égyptien de ce secteur
la cérémonie a été brève et marqué par
les acclamations enthousiastes des
soldats égyptiens qui se trouvaient sur
les lieux
c'est à midi aujourd'hui que le drapeau
israélien et est remplacé par celui de
l'egypte au dessus de la capitale du
sine
ce premier pas vers la restitution par
israël du sinaï tout entier auquel
n'assistait ni anouar el sadate et
menahem begin a donné lieu à des scènes
de liesse de la part de la population
d'el arish revenue à l'egypte après 12
ans d'occupation
un enthousiasme si grande ailleurs que
des soldats israéliens ont eu le plus
grand mal à protéger le bon déroulement
des cérémonies
pourtant tout ne va pas pour le mieux
entre jérusalem et le caire qui
s'opposent sur le calendrier de
l'ouverture des frontières et de
l'établissement de relations
diplomatiques normales pour israël ces
deux étapes devait être franchi en même
temps que la restitution d'el arish
ainsi que sa date l'avait promis à begin
en avril dernier mais sa date depuis a
changé d'avis la frontière ne sera
ouverte et des ambassadeurs échangé que
dans neuf mois conformément à la lettre
du traité de paix en fait il est certain
que sa date tient à garder le plus
d'atouts possible pour la suite des
négociations
justement deux heures à peine après les
cérémonies d'el arish s'ouvrait à
beersheva entre israéliens et égyptiens
et américains
les conversations sur l'autonomie de la
cisjordanie et de gaza
en l'absence d'ailleurs des principaux
intéressés les palestiniens les
conversations s'annonce difficile sur le
fond et orageuses dans la forme tant les
positions israéliennes égyptienne sion
drame diamétralement opposées pour gérer
salem l'autonomie pour les palestiniens
ne doit pas remettre en cause la
souveraineté israélienne sur les
territoires occupés alors que l'egypte
exige une autonomie conduisant à
l'autodétermination des palestiniens et
leur indépendance
c'est tout le processus de paix qui
risquent de s'enrayer cyrus vance
d'ailleurs n'a pas caché que pour lui
sans solution du problème palestinien
il n'y aura pas de paix au moyen-orient
quant au président sadate qui arrive à
el arish demain il a dit au forum de la
presse arrête du monte carlo il ya une
heure après j'avais préparé ma tombe
dans mon village natal mais je
demanderai qu'elle soit transférée au
sinaï où nous allons d'ailleurs bâtir
trois édifices pour les religions
monothéistes c'est à dire la musulmane
mais brahic et la chrétienne c'est
l'image que je voudrais laisser raid
histoire celle du respect de ces trois
religions qui sont une dans la
fraternité et la paix paris est début
aujourd'hui de la célébration du
printemps socialiste
cet après midi les représentants des
partis socialistes européens ont donné
une conférence de presse au théâtre de
l'empiré de l'étoile à paris
il y avait là entre autres personnalités
monsieur willy brand l'ex-chancelier
vehlmann fédéral mais ce james cameron
qui vient d'être pendant plusieurs
années
le premier ministre travaille
site de grande bretagne monsieur mario
soares qui est l'ancien premier ministre
portugais
l'actuel premier ministre du danemark
jorgensen et d'autres encore nombreux
entourant monsieur en solitaire cela
c'est respect proprement politiques
avant les festivités qui débute dans
trois quarts d'heure au palais de
chaillot et dans les jardins du
trocadéro
l'ensemble de ces manifestations par
daniel grandclément en commençant par la
politique
la présence de douze leader socialiste à
la même tribune c'est une image presque
familière
elle rappelle les journées de lille ou
de bruxelles pourtant quelque chose a
bougé les socialistes européens n'ont
jamais semblé si proche qu'aujourd'hui
deux raisons sans doute il n'ya plus de
programmes communs à long terme entre
socialistes et communistes français qui
donc ne se singularise plus enfin tous
les partis présents sont d'accord pour
défendre la social démocratie en tant
que représentant des exploités nous
sommes dans le même camp de l'égalité et
de la liberté devait dire françois
mitterrand on a eu un signe concret de
cette union avec la liste des quatre
cent soixante candidats qui se
présenteront sous les bannières
socialiste dans les neuf pays de la
communauté européenne
c'était donc l'événement politique
l'heure est maintenant à la fête
oui une fête qui va commencer dans trois
quarts d'heure et d'ailleurs il ya eu un
petit incident une tribune s'est
effondré heureusement il n'y a que des
blessés légers où je crois que très peu
donc dans quelques instants mélina
mercouri va va chanter ou du mois lire
des poèmes pour ouvrir cette soirée pour
le printemps socialiste
ensuite le london symphony orchestra
exécutera la symphonie fantastique de
berlioz
avant l'audition de chants
révolutionnaires et c'est vrai aussi la
politique ne paiera pas tout à fait ses
droits quand nous entendrons des textes
de françois mitterrand ainsi que de
villy brahms avec toute la journée on
s'est demandé s'il allait pleuvoir ou
pas parce que ce serait complètement
gâché la soirée
finalement ils semblent faire bon mais
on peut se demander c'est vrai qu'au
parti socialiste est presque une
habitude ce genre de fait déjà eu à
lille lors d'un lancement d'un homme du
lancement de la campagne européenne
on peut peut être se demander avec
l'homme qui conçoit ce genre de soirée à
quoi ça sert
cette soirée est destinée à célébrer
l'amitié entre les peuples d'europe et
en même temps à dire aux français au
parisien notre rôle c'est une europe de
la vie une europe ouverte 1
transformation du monde est vrai que les
meilleures façons vous êtes lac langage
je vais pas citer tout allait bien que
la meilleure façon de montrer ce que
vous dites est d'organiser des soirées
avec des orchestres des gens comme cela
c'est l'une des bannières l espace d'une
manière de rassembler ici la poule les
parisiens et j'invite les parisiens qui
ce soir son livre à se joindre à nous
c'est une fête libre une fête gratuite
et ils entendront à la fois nos messages
et une musique beneforte voilà donc qui
l'usic beneforte la soirée se terminera
vers 23h une entrevue que monsieur
georges marcheurs et eu avec françois
mitterrand
au lendemain du premier tour des
élections présidentielles de 1974 fait
l'objet d'une polémique entre le pcf et
le ps
hier monsieur laurent fabius porte
parole du parti socialiste a affirmé que
l'anecdote rapportée par monsieur
georges marchais est inventée de toutes
pièces ce soir voici la réponse de
monsieur pierre juquin au nom du pcf le
parti communiste français françois
mitterrand a dit je n'ai pas pu
rencontrer georges marchais sur jour là
c'est à dire le lendemain du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle de
1974 pour la simple raison que je
n'étais pas à la tour montparnasse
georges marchais non plus or je lis dans
l'unité du même jour de 1974
je lis que le lundi matin françois
mitterrand a rencontré les journalistes
devant une carte des départements
affiché dans son bureau de la tour
montparnasse cette carte des
départements que georges marchais lui
même a évoqué en rappelant ces faits je
lis dans la croix du lendemain du mardi
lundi monsieur mitterrand s'est
entretenu avec monsieur georges marchais
secrétaire général du parti communiste
français
jolie dans le figaro du mardi 7 mai 1974
la même chose monsieur mitterrand s'est
entretenu dans le courant de la journée
avec monsieur jean
alors la question se pose comment le
dirigeant d'un grand parti peut-il
proférer de telles contre vérités devant
des millions de téléspectateurs à
baisser ainsi lé débat des contre
vérités qui ne sont pas simples trous de
mémoire un simple oubli mais des
mensonges évidemment calculés de sang
froid
je m'interroge peut-être est-ce pour
faire diversion pour faire oublier qu'en
ce moment même françois mitterrand est
au trocadéro en train de parler avec le
leader socialiste allemand willy brandt
les français peuvent attendre un autre
débat un débat fondé sur la clarté sur
la vérité sur la loyauté
c'est ce débat là que propose le parti
communiste cette déclaration mais pour
ce qui nous concerne un point final à la
peta
la campagne officielle des élections
européennes s'ouvre au douzième coup de
minuit à 18h moment limite du dépôt des
listes
douze avaient été dénombrés mais l'une
d'entre elles n'a pas assorti sa demande
de la caution obligatoires trois vies se
sont déclarés in extremis celle du pays
su mener par madame bouchardeau celle de
leur droite de monsieur tic signe en
cours et celles de messieurs pierre
poujade malo et médecins défense
interprofessionnelle pour une france
indépendante dans une europe solidaire
l'enquète de gens consomment mercurol
daniel grandclément met en relief les
difficultés rencontrées par toutes les
petites listes
premier obstacle le nombre des candidats
pas facile de remplir sa liste
quand on sait d'avancé qu'un million de
suffrages est déjà insuffisant pour
avoir un élu mais la loi est formelle
si vous ne disposez que de 79 non je
sodomise de déférer votre liste au
conseil d'état donc vous avez tout
intérêt à me présenter une liste tout à
fait conforme à la loi avec 80 deuxième
barrage l'argent pour s'inscrire l'état
vous réclame une caution à remettre sous
forme de chèque
et si je vous fais un petit peu moins
d'inflation et de forme est récent et de
francs et comme rendez vous cet argent
en principe si vous obtenez 5% des
boîtes à condition que parce que la
demande avant l'expiration d'une année
et sinon la somme est acquise à l'italie
si votre liste dépasse 5% des voix au
plan national il suffit pas d avoir
dépassé dans un département vos frais
sont remboursés c'est à dire que on vous
remboursera votre cautionnement on vous
paiera le coût du papier que vous avez
utilisé pour faire imprimer vos
bulletins de vote et vos circulaire on
vous rembourse on a l'impression des
bulletins de vote et des circulaires les
affiches et les x d'affichage
une campagne comme les européennes ça
coûte environ 4 millions de francs deux
millions et demi pour les bulletins de
vote 1 million pour les professions de
foi et aussi deux cent mille francs
seulement pour les affiches des panneaux
électoraux
si vous ne désirez pas envoyé de
bulletins aux électeurs vous ne pouvez
donc imprimé que la moitié de vos
bulletins ce qui sera suffisant pour
approvisionner les murs de la danse car
avant d'aller voter les électeurs ne
seront pas informés les électeurs sont
tout de même informé puisqu'il y aura
une campagne à la radio et à la
télévision
donc on saura pop restée candidats
restent donc l'accès aux moyens
d'information mais là aussi le barrage
ne favorise pas les petites formations
deux heures d'émission pour les partis
ayant un groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale une demi heure
d'émission pour toutes les autres listes
ce temps est répartie également entre
elles sans que chacune puisse disposer
de plus de 5 minutes
monsieur bara et non d'entretien
aujourd'hui avec le premier ministre
luxembourgeois monsieur gaston thorn
deux sujets l'implantation de la
centrale nucléaire de tottenham et le
siège du parlement européen
nous continuons comme depuis quelques
jours notre lexique européens
aujourd'hui voici l'explication de ce
qu'est l'europe verte par jean-louis
comme les jeunes l'europe agricole
c'est aujourd'hui la somme d agriculture
des neuf pays qui la composent
s'il ya complémentarité entre les
agriculteurs et les agricultures de nos
différents pays
il y a aussi des divergences d'intérêts
et c'est là qu'intervient la politique
agricole commune
cette politique repose sur trois
principes de base un libre circulation
des produits dans la communauté de
soutien des prix de ses produits aux
agriculteurs des trois protection
uniforme des frontières vis-à-vis des
pays tiers mais l'europe agricole c'est
aussi un traité que des milliers de
fonctionnaires s'applique depuis
bruxelles à faire respecter pour fixer
les prix des produits agricoles
tous les ans au printemps s'engage à
bruxelles ce que l'on appelle le
marathon agricole il s'agit d'un
véritable marchandage ou exigences et
concessions font plus ou moins bon
ménage
les ministres de l'agriculture doivent
se mettre d'accord sur les prix de leurs
différents produits
après avis de la commission chargé des
questions agricoles
mais les ministres doivent aussi
s'entendre pour mettre au point de
multiples réglementations communes aux
neuf pays produit par produit en cas de
déséquilibre financier trop important
pour l'une des productions concernées
une caisse le fait aux gars fonds
européen d'orientation et de garantie
agricole vient en aide aux agriculteurs
concernés
enfin en cas de conflit sur
l'application des réglementations
c'est la cour européenne de justice qui
tranche en dernier ressort
l'europe verte c'est-à-dire
l'agriculture en europe
c'est aujourd'hui après 20 ans
d'existence le domaine où la
construction européenne est la plus
avancée
à l'élysée le conseil des ministres à
l'elysée le conseil des ministres s'est
penché aujourd'hui sur un plan de
nouvelles mesures d'économies d'énergie
la france a mis en place des 73 74 au
début de la crise un système qui permet
d'économiser l'équivalent de 15 millions
et demi de tonnes de pétrole par an mais
l'aggravation de la situation
internationale fait que d'ici à 1985
ces économies annuelles doivent être
doublées par un programme touchant
l'industrie le logement et le transport
dont l'automobile on connaîtra le plan
en juin avant deux grandes réunions
internationales de conseil européen de
strasbourg et le sommet des pays
industrialisés à tokyo répondant à une
question
monsieur un porte parole de l'elysée a
dit que pour l'automobile
le simple fait de respecter les
limitations de vitesse permettrait une
économie d'énergie substantielles
peut-être au prix de contrôle plus
strict la crise du pétrole est
évidemment un phénomène quasi mondiale
aux etats-unis le président carter top
d'imposer des mesures mais le parlement
a refusé le rationnement et son propre
parti lui est refusée hier la liberté
des prix du pétrole
en attendant ces gros consommateurs
d'essence que sont les automobilistes
américains s'affolent
après certaines mesures de rationnement
en califormie voici la situation dans
l'est des états unis
c'est à dire grosso modo la côte
atlantique un reportage de philippe gas
les américains sont installés dans la
crise avec pour la plupart un sens
civique qui force l'admiration car le
propos n'est plus de s'insurger contre
la pénurie mais d'éviter de perdre son
temps dans les files d'attentes
il est donc habituel maintenant de voir
les américains a mené du travail non pas
la maison mais dans la voiture dernière
histoire la mode de johnny carson
il est interdit de faire la cuisine dans
son automobile
deux heures d'attentes c'est plus qu'il
n'en faut pour avaler son déjeuner ou
pour terminer le pull-over au crochet
qui traîne depuis des semaines à la
maison ou comme il fait beau on en
profite pour s'occuper de soi
et puis il ya la lecture il faut compter
en période de crise
un livre tous les quatre jours une bonne
affaire pour les libraires alors combien
de temps avez vous attendu aujourd'hui
environ une heure c'est chaque jour la
même chose oui à peu près la même chose
et vous en pensez quoi
je pense qu'on est abusée par les
grandes compagnies pétrolières moi je
crois qu'il faut attendre qu'elle arrive
à un dollar et demi et il y en aura
plein d'essence parce qu'il n'y a pas
pénurie y en a peut-être chez les
détaillants
mais quand on paiera plus cher on aura
de l'essence ce n'est pas seulement mon
opinion le gouverneur de californie a le
même sentiment
sur la fréquence des radios taxi on nous
donne des conseils où on peut avoir les
sens combien y'a que enfin tout un tas
de trucs comme ça
la solution pour certains c'est le bon
vieux vélo à cause de la pénurie à los
angelès je fais 40 miles aller retour du
genre de mes colocs ans à prendre leur
vélo ou alors on a recours aux
privilèges de la motocycles c'est un
avantage ne fait plus de kilomètres on
se préoccupe pas du chiffre de sa plaque
qu'on peut avoir de l'essence tous les
jours et normalement on n'a pas à faire
la queue on passe devant les voitures et
on va directement la pompe
les autres recettes se débrouiller en
jouant avec la loi qui prévoit pour les
contrevenants des amendes de 2500 francs
ou de six mois de prison
dans une ville où les boulevards font 30
km de long et où les quartiers sont
distants parfois 200 km
la voiture est indispensable tout est
bon pour trouver le précieux liquide
envoyé sa petite amie à la pompe est ici
chose courant pour remplir sa voiture on
a recours à toutes les astuces
on monte parfois une véritable
organisation à plusieurs pour parvenir à
constituer des stocks parfaitement
illégaux et dangereux
tout comme le meilleur truc vous avez de
jerry caille vous garez votre voiture un
blog vous marcher jusqu'à la station
vous prenez cinq gallons à la pompe
vous allez les mettre dans votre
réservoir vous revenez en prendre cinq
gallons vous les mettez dans votre
réservoir et vous avez plein et au sujet
des étudiants les étudiants ils viennent
prendre votre voiture à la maison tu
vois votre bureau ils font la queue 2
août 6h mon rapport votre voiture et
vous les payez pour ça au sujet du
stockage le stockage pour les gens
riches comme ceux de bel air de malibu
de beverly hills
ils ont des réservoirs derrière leur
maison les marchands de jerry khan ont
vendus en deux semaines ce qu'ils
vendent habituellement en un an
quand il reste des bidons ils sont
placés dans la vitrine comme des
produits de luxe
on peut avoir recours à la voiture de
location qui est louée réservoir plein
et qui échappe aux plans de restriction
en tant que véhicule commercial les
grosses cylindrées elles restent au
garage
c'est durant les week-ends que l'essence
est introuvable 90 % des stations sont
fermées
alors pour aller prendre un bain à san
diego jouer quelques dollars à las vegas
les américains fortunés ont recours à
l'avion particulier malgré les conseils
du président carter il ne semble pas que
les américains soient prêts à se priver
ou alors il faudrait que les mentalités
changent rapidement
déjà on a annoncé que la fourniture du
carburant pour l'état de californie
serait augmentée dès le mois de juin
d'environ 6%
les gros consommateurs d'énergie que
sont les américains vont avoir bien du
mal à traverser la crise et à utiliser
dans leur vocabulaire le mot économie à
madrid
quatre militaires ont été tués dans un
attentat qui a été revendiquée peu après
par la branche militaire de
l'organisation séparatiste basque ont
été tués le général de metz sortie gois
la chef du personnel de l'armée de terre
deux colonels de son état major et un
sound
des détails par notre correspondant
permanent à madrid bruno alpes
madrid 9 heures 30 ce matin dans cette
voiture le directeur du personnel de
l'armée de terre le général comme est
sorti gueule à son adjoint et son
secrétaire deux colonels quittent leur
domicile
le véhicule roule lentement parce que
deux hommes s'approchent et se met à
tirer plusieurs rafale de pistolet
mitrailleur pour terminer il lance une
grenade puis s'enfuit dans une voiture
garée à proximité
les trois officiers de l'armée espagnole
sont morts ils ont été tués sur le coup
un peu plus tard c'est la branche
militaire de l'organisation séparatiste
basque eta qui revendique la
responsabilité de l'attentât dans un
appel téléphonique à la presse
ce n'est pas la première fois que l'été
as tu des officiers de l'armée espagnole
au mois d'octobre dernier le commandant
en second de la zone maritime de bilbao
a lui aussi été assassiné
l'objectif avoué de letea et de
provoquer une réaction brutale de
l'armée et de la droite espagnole pour
profiter les troubles qui pourraient
s'ensuivre revers fait faire notre
confrère correspondant du journal
allemand bert stern à beyrouth vient
d'être assassiné dans l'exercice de son
travail voilà qui porte à plus de 200 le
nombre de journalistes tués ou disparus
en mission depuis 1950 les guerres
d'indochine ont fait à elles seules 72
morts ou disparus parmi les journalistes
dont 20 pour les états unis et 18 pour
la france durant la guerre de corée 16
journalistes furent tués 11 de nos
confrères ont été fusillés au chili en
1975 et depuis quatre ans l'argentine
selon dhaif p 29 journalistes ont été
tués et 40 ont disparu
andré huguet andré league et est mort
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 81 77 et un
comédien très populaire est forte mais
du public
il avait joué d'innombrables succès au
théâtre et dès le début du cinéma il
avait fait une très belle carrière sur
l'écran d'abord au cinéma muet puis avec
le parlant il a ainsi créé pour le
cinéma
une centaine de rôles c'était dans ses
débuts le beau gosse un peu dominé il
réussit ensuite parfaitement dans les
séducteurs aux tempes légèrement
grisonnante cuisine fille d'un père
noble avec beaucoup d'à n'eurent une
extrême élégance bref un gentleman c'est
le perdre et comédienne rosine ligue 1
et aussi le père de pierre legrand
camarades disparus qui avaient des t
notes de nos meilleurs reporters
cameramen à l'occasion de la visite du
pape en pologne antenne 2 effectuera
plusieurs reportages en direct notamment
le 5 juin à midi l'angélus dans le
sanctuaire de la vierge de czestochowa
le surlendemain 7 juin messe dans
l'ancien camp de concentration de
birkenau le 10 juin et grand messe à
cracovie une série d'émissions
exceptionnelle et qui s'annonce très
émouvante et sur lesquels d'ailleurs
j'aurai l'occasion de revenir en détail
sport lafitte et de payer bliss et les
ligier risque de perdre une étape
importante dimanche au grand prix de
monaco
dans leur course au titre de champion du
monde de formule 1 les ligier ne se sont
pas mises en évidence au cours des
premières séances d'essais à cela une
raison majeure
les pilotes sont handicapés tous les
deux à la main droite dominée par leur
rival direct au championnat du monde
mais ferrari
la ville n'avait de scheckter et ligier
vont elles être réduites à de la
figuration
depuis le grand prix de belgique il ya
quinze jours l'inquiétude régnait dans
le clan ligier blessé au poignet à la
suite d'une sortie de piste alors qu'il
était en tête de la course
patrick de paillis était incertain pour
monaco incapable pendant plus d'une
semaine de conduire sa voiture
personnelle de payet a dû subir des
traitements intensifs pour être prêt à
temps pour ce que l'on considère comme
le grand prix le plus prestigieux de la
saison
apparemment même si la douleur est
encore présente pour lui la situation
s'est considérablement améliorée alors
qu'un certain optimisme pouvait se
justifier le coup de théâtre se
produisait quand jacques laffite à son
tour se mit à ressentir les effets très
aigu d'une vieille tendinite à l'avant
bras
salon ni beaucoup d'avoir ça ici parce
que alors visité embêté mais cette fille
est vraiment pas mal par rapport à
aujourd'hui
avant d'entamer la première séance
d'essais jacques laffite était incapable
de s'habiller de mettre son casque tout
seul confiant par nature en ses
possibilités
cette séance devait malgré tout mettre
en évidence les capacités des deux
éclopés de l'écurie ligier pour sa part
plus serein de paille et semblait prêt à
se crasher dans les mains et pour lui
malgré un sixième temps décevant
la situation devenait plus favorable qu
avant d'affronter le verdict de la fif
je pensais avoir plus de problèmes et
finalement ce serait le gage quand je
dois faire la course sans me faire
droguer
parce qu'il était envisagé de faire des
piqûres de nouveaux cahiers qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement pour que on
est l inquiétude vous concernant j'ai un
os de déplacés dans la main et c'était
douloureux jusqu'à je suis fière
aujourd'hui ça va nous
la fille à l'agonie souffrent le martyre
n'obtenait que le dix septième temps des
essais en tête ex-aequo du championnat
du monde des conducteurs avec jody
scheckter sur ferrari
il risque de perdre ici toutes ses
chances pour le titre mondial
le grand prix de monaco c'est plus de
2000 changement de vitesse en moins de
deux heures il est préférable dans ces
conditions d'avoir une main droite
valide
une chute en moto dijon ça se voit
rappeler à deux ans lorsqu'en plus de
france
un incident tennis et moi dernière mais
j'ai pas très bien soigné certainement
et là j'ai fait des essais intensifs ou
ricard pendant deux jours ça a déclenché
une crise qu'elles sont bien que
sandrine du championnat du monde
participeraient ou basse et des preuves
je participe à l'épreuve sa sens que je
fais 18/20 ou deuxième c'est pareil si
vous partiez sur la dernière ligne par
exemple vous n'avez pratiquement aucune
chance ne pas dire aucune chance s'est
jamais le savez une course est interdit
même en partant la volonté une qualité
qui ne suffira pas à la fif pour tenir
la distance du grand prix de payet quant
à lui pourrait en profiter pour
rejoindre au championnat sont bouillants
et briller en compagnon d'écurie
au tour d'italie cycliste italien
saronni a pris la tête du classement
général à l'issue de l'étape contre la
montre
francesco moser et à une minute deux du
leader du classement général et le
français michel laurent à 2 minutes 50
artistes ou toujours dauphiné libéré le
belge marc demeyer a remporté la
quatrième étape avignon balance il a
battu au sprint jacques esclassan lequel
conserve souvent nommé ouvert et au
classement général bernard hinault est
toujours en tête avec 9 secondes
d'avancé sur le néerlandais de
seine-et-marne joue comme elle et 23
secondes sur le belge vanille mais aussi
de meyer battant s class 3 nous en tous
les cas in au jeu de mail ghanim qui
sentent bon le tour de france football
ce soir une soirée capitale pour les
trois leaders qui jouent tous à
l'extérieur strasbourg à nancy bordeaux
à saint-etienne et nantes à nice vous
aurez les résultats dans notre dernière
édition
veillée d'armes demain pour les 39
bateaux huit monocoques qui ont ce
trimaran qui prendront le départ du mas
veillée d'armes aujourd'hui car ils
prendront le départ demain à 13 heures
de la course transatlantique en double
lorient les bermudes lorient plus de dix
mille kilomètres 5000 contre le vent à
l'aller et 5000 aux allures portantes
autour l'emploi niable promet d'être
rude
parmi les concurrents il ya les favoris
naturellement mais aussi les touristes
départ donc demain ou canon à 13h et
vous pourrez les suivre un direct dans
notre édition samedi la transat en
double une nouvelle transat à la
française après la course de la route du
rhum en double pour deux raisons parce
qu ils seront 2 par bateau et puis
surtout parce que les concurrents qui
partent de lorient doivent aller virer
une bouée aux bermudes et revenir à
lorient soit 6000 milles nautiques près
de 10000 km ils seront 40 au départ de
lorient samedi à 13 heures dont les plus
grands noms de la course au large
michael birch vainqueur de la course de
la route du rhum il repart sur un
trimaran plus grands michel malinovski
deuxième derrière birch reprend son
grand monocoque c'est l'homme de la
fidélité
olivier de kersauson qui vient de perdre
son trimaran embarque cette fois sur un
monocoque
enfin eric tabarly le plus célèbre
navigateur français fait une nouvelle
fois preuve de son génie des bateaux il
a fait construire un hydrofoil
c'est-à-dire un bateau qui s'élève sur
des patins à partir d'une certaine
vitesse
c'est en principe le bateau le plus
rapide il doit pouvoir atteindre 30
noeuds environ 55 km heure c'est en
vérité comme l'était son pen duick iv un
bateau révolutionnaire ma profiler en
aile d'avion et pivotant pour offrir le
moins de prise au vent poutres
transversales incidences variables pour
orienter les folles tabarly c'est la
volonté de gagner même si son bateau
tardivement terminé n'est pas encore au
point
pour d'autres la majorité des autres
concurrents sur les 40 seules une
dizaine peuvent espérer gagner
les motivations sont bien différentes
c'est la passion de la mer qui est le
plus souvent à l'origine de
l'inscription dans cette course et il
faut être passionné pour accepter de
partir 40 ou 50 jours sur la mer alors
quelle est votre motivation
faire une grande course au large et puis
comme c'était très difficile de la faire
en tant qu'équipe hier parce que j'ai
jamais pu liane comprend 1 bat sourit on
l'a fait mais avec l'espoir de gagner ou
de non pas du tout on est incapable de
gagner beaucoup de gens qui seront donc
ce qui est normal cet échange des
bateaux comme malinowski et comme le
tabac redit comme meilleure chose qu'on
peut pas espérer gagner c'est pas
possible
c'est un métier pour vous la voix du
nord pour tony molino et à la zone de
suisse la transat en double c'est en
quelque sorte un galop d'essai avant
d'aller explorer le triangle des
bermudes et essayer d'expliquer ses
mystères en contre l'ami qui était
rédacteur en chef d'une revue qui
s'occupait des choses bizarres et en
discutant g je fais le pari pratiquement
en audience est organisée une discussion
j'aurais été là bas parce que moi
j'avais simplement des questions
méthodologiques sont beaucoup plus
croire tenue molino reconnaît pourtant
que certains vestiges sont troublants il
était livré à des pyramides abîme unis
il était docker dont je pense qu'il sait
il existe et utilisation qui ont vécu on
est aidé par voie royale aux mâles plan
mais de là à la croate n'est donc pas
seulement une course pour les marins
célèbre c'est aussi un vivier de marins
mendiants perpétuellement sur les mers
pour satisfaire une passion dévorante la
célébrité si elle arrive un jour n'est
pour eux qu'un moyen pour aller plus
loin et plus longtemps
la météo demain samedi le ciel sera le
plus souvent très nuageux ces nuages
seront localement accompagnés de pluies
ou d'averses parfois barrage cependant
on verra des éclaircies le matin près de
la méditerranée et l'après midi dans
l'ouest les vents seront faibles ou
modérés et les températures en légère
hausse de quoi être assez timidement
optimiste pour le week end
le dernier journal où sera présenté à
bernardino n'oubliez pas demain samedi
et demi et à 20 heures je continuerai le
point avec vous bonsoir merci